توصفوا بخزان العالم الاستراتيجي من
الموارد الطبيعيه والمواد الاوليه
60% من اراضيها صالحه للزراعه ولكنها
للاسف غير مزروعه رغم هذه الارقام تستورد
البلدان الافريقيه كل عام اكثر من 70% من
احتياجاتها من القمح وقد فقمت الحرب
الروسيه على اوكرانيا معاناه العديد من
الاقتصادات الافريقيه الهشه وفقا لبيانات
البنك الدولي تمتلك افريقيا احتياطيات
كبيره من المعادن الاساسيه وتعتبر منجما
ضخما ينتج كميات كبيره من المعادن كالذهب
والالماس والبلاتين والكوبالت والحديد
ولا نكتفي بالحديث عن هذه الثروات
المعدنيه دون الحديث عن ثروات النفط
والغاز حيث تتمتع القاره باحتياطيات تتركز
في عدد من البلدان وتضعها على خريطه
الطاقه عالميا وفقا لتقرير للاتحاد
الافريقي على مدار خمسين عاما خسرت
افريقيا اكثر من التريليون دولار لصالح
التدفقات الماليه غير المشروعه هذا يعادل
تقريبا كلما تلقته من مساعده امائيه رسميه
خلال الفتره نفسها وكان مخزون راس المال
الافريقي سيرتفع بنحو 60 في المئه لو بقيت
الاموال التي غادرت افريقيا بشكل غير
قانوني في القاره لكن تبقى النزاعات
وانعدام الامن من التهديدات والتحديات
التي تقود التنميه في القاره الافريقيه
فخلال العامين الماضيين فقط هزت سته
انقلابات عسكريه منطقه الساحل والصحراء في
غرب افريقيا والقاره الافريقيه لوحدها
مسرح لاكثر من اربعين في المئه من
النزاعات المسلحه في العالم سنويا تدور في
نحو 20 دوله في القاره وقد ترتب على
استمرار النزاع ان ثلاثه من البلدان
الاربعه التي تواجه تهديدا خطيرا بالمجاعه
تقع في افريقيا رغم كل ذلك وبين تحديات
الامن والتنميه ومتى تمتع به من خيرات
افريقيا قاره الفرص تتغير